in this video i'm going to show you
exactly how you can create this image
that i sourced from instagram and
replicate it in archicad 25. so we're
going to be starting with this image
here in arcade 25 and we're going to
walk you through it step by step first
of all we're going to start by pressing
command and 7 to bring up
our story settings as you can see in
this picture it looks relatively low so
what we're going to do is change so what
we're going to do is change our story
settings to manipulate what we can see
in this image i'd be assuming that our
ground floor plan which is the bottom of
this picture would be about two four
four five and then we'd have about a 250
millimeter slab in our structure or our
ground ceiling our first floor would
again be two four four five
and again 250 millimeters of structure
but looking at this there is that small
little 50 millimeter gap between the
first and the second floor to make it
seem like it's floating so we're going
to bump that up to about 300 millimeters
and we're going to change our story
settings here to say first ceiling so we
can delete all that extra we can insert
one more above and go second floor
that second floor is definitely a little
bit higher than the rest of them so
let's call that 3045
and we're going to leave it at that for
now we don't need any of those ticked so
we can completely remove those off and
press ok what you'll see here on the
layout indicator panel is that they have
now changed for us so traditionally
speaking i'd be telling you to use this
second view map in our layout book
instead of our project map but for
simplicity we'll keep it on the project
map let's start with our ground floor
and just scroll across somewhere where
it's not too important we're not worried
about our elevation and our section
markers we're going to start with our
ground floor and we're going to focus
predominantly on creating this image
that we see in front of us we're not
going to worry about anything behind
anything internally we're just going to
keep it very simple very basic so let's
start with our wall tool make sure we
are on walls external
and that we select a wall type that we
feel appropriate for me personally i'm
just going to go 90 millimeter stud
doesn't matter what wall system you
select so i'm going to estimate that
this driveway in the middle is about
four meters wide and then i'm going to
estimate we've got two meters on one
side and probably about another four
meters on another side which gives us an
overall length of about 10 meters now
i'm going to start by basically
mirroring this image onto our page so
what you see in the left hand corner is
going to be the left hand corner of my
screen so if we click once hold shift
press d type 4 000 to give us 4 meters
and then we're going to go hold shift
press d type 6 000
to get six meters back into our garage
again continuing that process i believe
that entry is four meters wide we're
coming back even and level with the
front of our house and then going back
two meters and now all i'm going to do
is simply drag it back down about 15
meters
and finish that entire thing off as a
completed box so now we're going to
select these two orgs here and if you
have all of your walls connected we're
going to press option g or alt g to
ungroup and then we're simply going to
click on that little node go down to our
fillet or chamfer
and introduce a rounded corner so i'm
going to guess and
do a little bit of trial and error here
to understand what size corner that is
we're going to start with 2 000
millimeters or 2 meters which creates a
rounded corner here i think that's a
little bit too much so command and z
will undo that let's bring that down to
a one metre corner and that's starting
to look a lot better we're going to do
the same thing on this side one meter
rounded corner gives us the look we're
looking for next we're going to come
across to our window tool and we're
going to basically create these four
doors down the bottom that we see so we
can easily use any of the archicad
windows so for example this horizontal
multi sash is almost perfect for us
we're just going to extend that to four
meters wide we're going to extend that
to 2400
high and click ok
and then we're simply going to drop it
into the center of our wall
and finish that window off if we come up
to our marquee tool make sure we select
the thicker dashed lines to show us all
of the levels
marquee right click show all in marquee
we're going to see what we've started to
create in 3d so first of all our window
is way too high up we can reduce that
seal height back to zero
so it goes back down to the ground and
if we go command or control t we can
open up our settings go to our material
attributes and then change all of that
to black so that it matches the image
that we see in front of us pressing okay
looking at this image we're starting to
create something very very similar now
there's a number of ways we can create
this timber pattern on the bottom the
easiest way is through a material
texture alternatively we can do it with
a cladding system but in this video i'm
just going to show you a material
texture now arcade by default doesn't
have anything that looks like this so
what we're going to do is jump on google
right now and try and find a nice
orangey earthy timber texture tone so
what i've done is simply jumped onto
google typed in timber cladding texture
seamless found an image that i like
right click save to downloads and then
if we come back to our archicad model
now a quick little interlude for you
guys if you're looking for anything
architecture or archicad related make
sure you check out davidtomich.com.u
it's the first link in the description
you'll find everything that you need we
can come up to window toolbars and then
down to attributes which is going to
introduce this brand new little toolbar
we can come up to our surface textures
material
go to something similar so if we find
our timber or wood grain let's try find
a wood light oak we're going to go new
vertical cladding and we're going to
duplicate that system entirely so we
have all of that wood texture already
created next what we're going to do is
change our light wood texture so we're
going to go to browse add and in our
downloads we're going to find exactly
that image we just created so we're
going to open that up we're going to let
archicad introduce that image directly
in to our project we're going to keep
the original proportions so we don't
mess with how it looks on screen then
we're going to click ok go back to our
attributes and we're going to duplicate
that once more so we go horizontal
cladding click ok and jumping back to
our vertical system we're just going to
change that to 90 degrees so it goes
vertical pressing ok closing our
attributes panel now we can easily
select the main walls in our project
that we see as timber press command or
control t and override our surfaces to
wood vertical cladding now if we press
ok we'll see that's automatically been
created and replicated into archicad
straight away we're starting to look a
lot like the image we see in front of us
now if we go to our first floor right
click on the ground floor and go show as
trace reference we're going to see where
our project currently lies if we then go
to our slab tool we're gonna be able to
create a slab somewhere over that
section there so we're hanging over this
garage but not by too much so i'm gonna
come all the way back here type in 1500
minus so it automatically calculates the
difference between where it was and
where it needs to be now we need to
create a very smooth sleek line on the
right hand side of this image that
slowly curves back
in to the boundary wall over here so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a new hotspot in the middle here
roughly in the middle of our driveway
and then we're going to curve that
corner and i'd like to curve it let's
start by 3 meters test that out that's a
very harsh steep curve probably a little
bit too much so we'll drop that down to
two meters and try again coming back to
our 3d marquee we'll see that we're
starting to get that shape in now i've
just realized that's completely back to
front and i should have realized that a
long time ago so what we're going to do
is select everything on the 3d model
spin around to the back control or
command m
find the center of our slab click once
hold shift click again and mirror that
entirely so now that we look from the
front we're looking picture for picture
next i'm going to click on this slab
click command t go to generic
and change that to concrete and i'm
going to reduce the slab edge down to
only 10 millimeters now this is not a
structural tutorial this is mainly an
architectural modeling replication
to be able to actually introduce what
we're looking for so if we come back to
our first floor now hold our old button
to get the eyedropper tool over the
timber walls below
and then what we're going to do is
simply follow our curved wall lines of
the slab below if we then again press
the eyedropper tool align ourselves with
the center of that mullion below we can
then create
the setback window
in this image that we're seeing on the
left hand side by reducing our wall back
leaving our
outrigger here on the right hand side
and coming back into 3d you'll see that
we're slowly starting to create what we
see in this image now next we want to
focus on those angled slab and angled
roof diving back into our main window of
this living area so if we create this
window first we're going to be able to
articulate these roof lines and slab
lines a lot quicker and a lot easier now
let's come back into our first floor
plan let's go back to our window tool
and open up our window settings i'm
simply going to select window 25
and make that a fixed glass sash i'm
going to drop it in in 3d
and drag it out to the size that i need
which is all the way across that entire
property window
now as you can see that window is
probably too big too large so i'm going
to offset it 300 mil from the bottom and
increase the height of it to 300ml from
the top and change the material of it as
well so now we have one large glass
plane window that we can start
changing our materials with looking back
at it we probably don't need that to be
10 mil it can be the full 250 ml like we
originally planned so that it comes back
up to the bottom and will soon cut the
bottom of this slab in a very unique way
so we want to come back to our floor
plan we want to use our roof tool now
and we want to create a small roof
structure on both the top and bottom now
the easiest way we've created that roof
very quickly we can come back down to
our 3d we can change our roof structure
this is just the generic modeling shell
so this definitely can be 10 mil and it
definitely needs to be concrete as well
we can adjust that down to the bottom of
our slab so it cuts back in
and we can start lowering the angle
until it's perfect with the bottom of
that window so 20 degrees in this
instance is absolutely perfect it's
probably a little bit too steep
comparing it to the image so if we
wanted to increase this window and
decrease the
pitch of that roof we absolutely could
next we're going to click on this slab
right click connect solid element
operations and then we're going to
select our roof adders operator subtract
with up and go execute that's going to
cut off and create that pitch that we're
looking for and again i still think
that's way too steep so i'm going to
decrease that down to 10 maybe 15 and
increase the size of this window so it
looks a little bit better then i'm going
to click command d and press the option
button to be able to then replicate that
roof above
change it to minus 15 and adjust the
window to suit perfectly so there we go
we've started to create our angles we've
started to create our windows and we've
started to create our curves so far
we're three quarters of the way through
and there isn't much left in this
project what i'm going to do now is make
sure that all the materials of this
concrete are exactly the same so i'm
going to override all of the surfaces on
the slab and the walls to concrete light
23 and there we go now all of our
surfaces are exactly the same and we can
continue on with our last or second
floor so coming back up to our second
floor in our project map we can right
click and show as trace for our first
floor so we know where we actually are
working coming back to our slab tool
like we originally did we're going to
this time create a slab slightly skewed
to one side so by the looks of it the
easiest way we can do this is by
replicating the size of our slab below
offsetting two meters from one side
dragging it forward what looks like
about a meter and a half and then
showing our ground floor as our trace
reference pressing control or command e
using the right hand nodes to be able to
angle our project across looking at it
it might be about 10 degrees which
appears to be approximately perfect
because it doesn't touch that boundary
it doesn't go all the way across and
coming back and showing our first floor
as our trace reference again so we
understand where we are once again we're
probably a little bit too close so we're
going to drag that out by pressing
command d another one meter last but not
least i'm just going to simply extend
this slab all the way to the edges more
so for me personally than anything else
because that's how it would be
constructed
and coming back to our 3d so we can see
what we've created
then we're going to reduce our slab
height to 200 millimeters rather than
250 so we can create that floating
levitating effect that we're looking at
before again it appears that we have
that same 15 degree pitch roof and floor
lines coming in on that so we're going
to be able to create that in a second
we're going to open up our slab settings
and change all of our
surfaces so on the bottom we're going to
have our wood cladding horizontal on the
sides we're going to have our wood
cladding vertical and on the top we're
probably going to have our wood cladding
horizontal as well pressing okay to make
sure i got that correct yep so now we
can see that our wood cladding is on the
bottom of our slab it's on the sides of
our slab and we can continue with the
surfaces above coming back to our first
floor plan it's relatively simple we can
show as trace reference for our ground
floor plan use the walls below because
they're already timber
again drawing the box out and a square
using the slab we've created already
taking that main front wall dragging
that back what appears to be three three
and a half meters it's quite far back in
quite deep so let's go three and a half
meters for the purpose of argument go
back to our window tool
introduce a small window on the side
and bring that larger which looks to be
about two meters wide coming back to our
3d we can see that we've started to
create our top floor and what we can do
is actually replicate our slabs from the
first floor so holding the alt button
again coming up to our second floor we
can once again create our roof then go
back to 3d understand where that window
is actually meant to sit that doesn't
look as steep because it's quite far and
quite deep so i'm going to reduce that
five degrees across the whole pitch
increase the size of our window
extend our roof to the top and adjust
our window once again so now that that
has been created i'm going to go through
and change all these materials to match
the timber as we need and then by the
looks of things looks like we have a
batten system across the front of our
wall now again multiple ways to be able
to create this if we come into our
second floor at the top the easiest way
which isn't very
customizable later on is by creating a
consistent timber column start with a
contour open up our settings
make that a 25 by 25
timber batten and change our material
across to timber and then we can drop
one of our columns directly in here
bring it to the front so we can actually
see what we're doing command d
rotate it around to match our wall
offset 25 offset 25 and then we can
click in the center go to our distribute
or our multiply tab at the end
distribute jump across the spread and
let's make that a 40 millimeter
distribution so now if we click on one
corner and drag it all the way across to
our window we can create a series of new
columns very very quickly and very
repetitively group them together so we
can move them and edit them easily come
back to 3d
and we'll see that we've created
our timber batten system and that's all
for me today guys my name is david
thomich and i'll see you next time